make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay so we are covering Justice League
the six dimension and I know I'm behind
on this I know like a bunch of other
coming book youtubers have covered it
don't care I am excited about this story
I am hyped about this story okay
Justice League the sixth dimension is
probably one of the coolest stories to
come out of DC Comics for like a long
time right so initially like when it
comes to Scott Snyder like writing like
really writing Justice League in general
emember all this is like one part it's
like a part of a big cohesive story
right like the end result is Perpetua
and like her return and a manipulation
of like really like the omniverse not
even the multiverse but like the
omniverse uh and then like there's gonna
be a couple other cures that kind of get
thrown in here but it's all sort of like
leading up to that moment right like
it's ever since we had like the first
fracture of the source wall that landed
on earth and the first volume of the
Justice League running all the way up
until now and going into like year of a
villain and all that kind of stuff this
all focuses heavily on the character of
perpetuo the villain of Perpetua who
just hasn't showed up yet for the most
part well I think in year of the villain
she may have but there but basically
like she's trying to make her return now
initially this leads into the generally
I guess it picks up with the Justice
League kind of coming together now a
couple things to bear in mind here
remember Mira is currently the queen of
Atlantis right like Aquaman's off doing
his own thing and it was a way for DC to
kind of focus on Aquaman's character
absent the Justice League itself so
really like his ongoing series is kind
of isolated now it's kind of like cut
off from like everything else going on
in DC it's cool and it's really good but
it isn't really 14-2 like the overall
Justice League as a whole and there's a
couple things going on here in there but
for the most part it's kind of removed
but the whole reason why the Justice
League is here is because what they've
done is they've gone forward with a
purpose of like bringing back a classic
character that we haven't seen for a
long time of course this classic
character is revealed when the guy makes
his return when he was supposed to show
up at this point in time and it turns
out to be mr. Mixel pedelec now the
question a lot of people are probably
wondering is where has mr. Mixel pedelec
been like what's he been doing this
entire time
oh I can tell you exactly what he's been
doing he's been using Skillshare hashtag
sponsored video this video sponsored by
Skillshare Skillshare is an online
learning community for creators with
more than 25,000 classes in design
business and more and premium
memberships give you unlimited access so
you can actually join the classes and
communities that are just right for you
now if you guys are looking to like
topple me and become like the next
comics explained which is entirely
they got classes on graphic design
photography creative writing film and
video marketing productivity all that
kind of good stuff
all the things that can basically like
get you on the road to becoming the new
comments explained and to get you
started skills share is giving away a
free two month unlimited access trial to
the first 500 people who clicked a link
in the description and after that it's
only around ten dollars a month having
said that uh we actually don't know what
mr. Mitchell public's been doing this
entire time we really don't and that's
kind of an interesting thing right
because like you go from like Superman
reborn
we're like Mixel pedelec has been
pretending to be Clark Kent this entire
time and then basically like you end up
with like the new 52 and the three new
52 Superman merging into one another to
mix up it like vanishing and then we
have no idea of where he went to but the
funny thing about this this is actually
kind of a cool display of power is this
is kind of a story that I would say
would be an introductory place for
people who were new to his character
right because um he doesn't appear all
the time I mean used to be that he would
appear not all the time but like more
frequently than he does now but I think
since the beginning of DC rebirth he's
probably shown up like maybe twice if
you consider Superman reborn like him
showing up twice in that story so I
guess be in there for like the whole
story so in reality anybody who's going
through and like reading DC Comics right
now has probably never heard of him so
what Scott Snyder does is give us this
kind of grand display of the power that
Mixel pedelec has and literally like he
just turns the world of the Justice
League upside down like Jon Stewart the
Green Lantern goes to launch an attack
in Mitchell pedelec just like starts
breaking his body down it's cool things
like that cuz you don't really see this
and that's one of the big differences
between like Marvel and DC Comics front
like Marvel Comics you have a lot of
reality walkers right you have the
Beyonder you have the beyonders you've
got the molecule man Owen Reese you've
got the cosmic entities you've got
Galactus you've got classic silver
server from the 1980s you've got all
kinds of like crazy power you know
people with with crazy powers in DC it's
a lot more grounded in terms of like
extreme capabilities and extreme powers
you don't really see those and so seeing
this in here is actually kind of cool
but of course then that goes into John
Jones foreseeing a mission of Hitler to
start like saying his name in his own
mind without saying it out loud now for
people who are new to this whenever
Mixel pedelec says his name out loud
he's sent back to the fifth dimension
right it's the one way to kind of get
rid of him and that's the sort of
ongoing joke that goes on with his
character right whenever he shows up he
bothers Superman for a while Superman
has to use his intellect and trick Mixel
pedelec into saying his name backwards
I'm sorry saying his name backwards the
right way and in order to send him back
to his own dimension now of course the
reason why Mixel peddler doesn't pull
that stunt with Batman is who's back
would be he would like to play some mind
games and then like Mitchell pedelec
would end up saying his own name and
then going back to his dimension before
he even realized what happened butit's
kind of a cool thing because what Mixel
pedelec says is like the impact of the
Justice League destroying the source
wall and the kind of cascading effect
that it takes throughout the entire
multiverse isn't just felt in like their
native dimension it's felt in like the
fifth dimension right like it spreads
throughout everything and that's when
things get a little bit hairy because
what ends up happening here is we sort
of get this this explanation that things
are not as limited as we thought they
were that things are not as basic as we
thought they were they're what Mitchell
pedelec does is it County comes forward
it says okay there's like a whole host
of multiverses out there and for the
most part in DC Comics we only ever
really assumed there was just one right
like there was a positive multiverse and
the negative multiverse and that was
basically it but like the negative
multiverse was more of like a reflection
right it was a darker and more evil and
twisted and in hopeless reflection of
the positive multiverse Mitchell pedelec
says no no no it's not like that but you
have this you have a singular multiverse
and then like the third dimension is the
one that we occupy and then you have
like time which is the fourth dimension
and then you have the fifth dimension
which is just pure imagination fully
walk on the Chocolate Factory a world of
pure imagination like that kind of a
thing and then the sixth dimension is
the one that nobody really knows
anything about because only individuals
of the highest order are allowed to go
there not only that we actually kind of
get this explanation that what Perpetua
did is she had like what were
essentially like three suns right it was
the mana of the monitor at the
anti-monitor and then the world forger
and the kind of cool thing about this is
the world forager as he's depicted here
we've seen him in the dark multiverse or
at least the dark multiverse version of
him and so again like it's it's kind of
cool to see Scott Snyder making these
callbacks to like stories that he's
written in the past would again is
actually pretty sweet but the idea
behind this is that there are like
multiple multiverses out there right
like throughout the entire omniverse
there's a whole host of multiverses and
like all those multiverses have their
own individual universes and that
perpetuo was kind of the creator of this
multiverse and presumably the creator of
woke seemed to kind of be all others now
how we reconcile that with like the
presence right like DC's absolute God
it's kind of difficult to do because
when it comes to the presence in DC
Comics that's largely a vertigo concept
right you know Lucifer Morningstar and
and Michael the Archangel all that kind
of stuff that's all really vertigo and
you never really see a crossover with
like the main DC Universe line of
stories and so because that's the case
we can kind of assume they're two
distinctly different different things
neither
one having a bearing on the other and so
with that being the case we just sort of
take that a little bit of information
and just kind of run with it but the
overall gist here is that in order for
them to truly understand what's going on
they have to enter the sixth dimension
and see how far this goes and see if
they can't like find a way to at the
very least solve things now there are a
couple of things that kind of get
mentioned in here for example like the
Justice League has hidden from the from
humanity the fact hidden from everybody
on earth the fact that they broke the
source wall they're like the multiverses
spiraling towards its inevitable doom
and then the reason why is because if
the Justice League came out and said ok
everybody fYI we kind of broke the
source wall and so because that the
entire multiverse is hurling to its
imminent doom which will probably happen
in like a few weeks or so society is
going to completely and totally collapse
right it's it's gonna totally fall apart
and so of course what Mitchell fiddling
says and this is kind of a throwaway
Moeller from Scott Snyder but we can
kind of accept it what Mitchell piddling
says is that like with Batman as
Superman they're essentially like like
that might you know kind of the the
Batman equivalent of like Mitchell
Hitler is a ohia in in Mixel pedelec
himself are the two most powerful mmm
like the 5th dimension and so in the
various escapades the various instances
was emitted when mixup hit like had
shown up and kind of bothered Superman
what he'd been doing was essentially
just like kind of bombarding him with
energy that would allow him to access
the six dimension now again this is
really kind of a Scott Snyder just
grabbing that throwing it in for the
purpose of just being like we need a
reason for Superman to be able to go in
and he's the only one that can go in so
like mix up hit a lick made it happen
it's a very hand wavy kind of throwaway
thing but it works for the nature of the
story right I mean you can kind of
yes you know and then just kind of gonna
go with it and just sort of call it a
day
what what is up happening is Superman
passes to the door and then immediately
comes back and like he's older and I
have to say let's be honest with
ourselves here all right I know like
Jorge or hegemonist who I think I think
it's Jimenez is how you pronounce his
last name the guy doing the art for this
comic Superman looks amazing do you like
old man Superman looks awesome and like
do here's the crazy thing he's basically
almost godlike in power but then then
like we get this kind of rug pulled out
from under us right because it's like
hey welcome to the Hall of Justice which
is unlike the future of what your
universe is going to be and it's crazy
and it looks amazing and all that kind
of cool stuff and then we get the rug
pulled out from under us when we
actually end up running into like actual
Superman who's just kind of on this
singular planet of sorts in this almost
infinite expanse of nothingness
surrounded by like all these dead
versions of himself and so it's kind of
like okay so like what in the world is
going on right now what in the world is
happening right now and it's kind of a
cool thing because what is up happening
is that when that with the rest of the
Justice League being unaware of the fact
that Superman is missing because as far
as they're aware this is him he's just
kind of been here for decades and
basically they won the war against
Perpetua and everything the Justice
League hoped would happen ended up
taking place he basically says like you
know before we answer any questions
before we get too much into things just
go explore the world I go explore this
world and just see where it leads you
and like in this world that they occupy
it's basically perfect but it's like a
perfect world it's pretty cool the way
it works for example Jon Stewart has
become the white lantern and like this
future a future version of Barry and Jon
has basically figured out a way to to
like run in and out and to kind of move
freely throughout the timestream without
creating any kind of fracture without
breaking anything and so the way this
works is it's almost kind of like the
end of Jonathan Hickman's
Secret Wars right where like Jon Stewart
basically uses the life entity to like
create life on worlds and then Barry
figures out where to put them in the
timestream it's actually really cool
like it's really awesome like they're
creating entire multiverses everything
is kind of orchestrated and built out of
like this place that they occupy this
space at the rent they associate is kind
of like seed the multiverse seed new
worlds the whole nine yards they're
essentially gods and is it's kind of
cool the way this plays out because
didn't you switch over to Gotham City
and Gotham City is a utopia and it's
kind of a funny thing because that's
sort of what Bruce Wayne was always
fighting for white light to lead Gotham
City to a place even if he didn't
necessarily live long enough to
get there but to lead it to a place
where Gotham was kind of like not really
like a metropolis but like something
better where was a place that people
wanted to be it was a place of spiritual
and emotional you know growth in and
relaxation a place where people could be
at peace to see Gotham has finally
achieved that and to see that it's kind
of maintained the legacy of Batman by
constructing and Max's a massive statue
of to his legacy is kind of an honorable
thing not only that we actually end up
finding out that like Dick Grayson has
taken over the mantle of Batman that
Dick Grayson is like the guy who's
basically you know kind of maintaining
or at least not really may not even
maintaining order the guy who's kind of
overseeing all these things but again
like this is this is a perfect world
this is a perfect life this is what the
Justice League has always been shooting
for and so again kind of jumping back to
Superman who's in this like this bleak
and dark environment we end up having
like this what was supposedly his future
version this this future version of
himself who shows up it says hey look
man this can go one of two ways
either you can like stop fighting and
you can basically join my cause you can
see things away that I see them and
become a part of what it is that we're
trying to achieve here or you can be
left behind and be one of these
countless bodies is sort of just dotting
this landscape here and die in this
place and it's kind of a crazy thing
because what he is of saying is like
that light up there that that Sun that
you basically see will not be there
forever and it's enough to keep you
sustained but it's not gonna be enough
for you to really like use your powers
your powers will eventually drain right
the solar energy you have built up in
yourselves will eventually drain out and
like you're gonna die in this place so
answer me now like are you going to join
me or are you not going to join me and
ultimately by virtue of his thoughts and
feelings
Superman says no and so that basically
leaves him to just kind of be down there
and try to find a way out for himself
but nobody else really knows what's
going on and that's what we kind of
switch back over to Batman again right
I'm gonna kind of talk about this for a
minute you switch back over to Batman
and we end up finding out that Arkham
Asylum has been torn down the villains
are no longer an issue anymore and that
while Alfred Pennyworth died after the
Great War you know with perpetuo and all
that kind of stuff
that wound up happening was Arkham was
basically replaced with like this sort
of pennyworth home for individuals who
were like looking for a reprieve right
like people who are looking to kind of
get back to their senses or to find a
place of respite of relaxation that's
what this is for and that Barbara Gordon
plays a pretty big role in helping
people get there but it's kind of a
crazy thing because when all that
happens of course we also end up finding
out that in this future Hawkgirl and
Martian Manhunter ended up having a
child together and that's when Martian
Manhunter uses his telepathy pulls
everybody in and says this world is not
what it seems to be this world is not
what you guys think it is this is a dark
place here we don't know
how dark this place is but this is all
in illusion this place is a place of
darkness a place of suffering in a place
of paint and that's when their child
kind of kind of pops up and says I'm the
one that showed them what this were at
least told them what this world is
really like it's not a paradise it's not
a utopia it is in a lot of ways and
absolute living hell and so what is it
going on is of course while this kind of
message is being conveyed by the kid
suddenly this older version of Superman
pops up and says I will explain what it
is that's going on I will tell them
what's happening and of course once he
imprisons the Justice League mentally
that he simply goes through and starts
to say the person that I am is to not
Superman I took on this form to come for
you I took out in this form so you
wouldn't walk in here and immediately
feel like you had to be on your guard I
wanted your guards down and I wanted you
to relax not so I could destroy you and
kill you but so that you could be in a
place to where when I reveal Who I am
you're not going to immediately try to
attack me now of course this is the
Justice League they attack first and
then ask questions later but this guy
reveals himself to be the world fortress
now again I want to talk about this for
a second because this world for is your
concept is relatively new and the reason
why is the idea of like the I guess a
forger of worlds really kind of came
about with like Dark Knight's metal
right eye all we really knew is that in
the dark multiverse you had some system
by which worlds were being created and
when those worlds were created they were
being judged if they were worth staying
they'd be allowed to go up into the
multiverse and become part of the
multiverse if they were not they would
be kept down there and they would remain
within the dark multiverse of course
that led to all different kinds of crazy
and twisted alternate realities like the
flash Batman hybrid Red Death and like
you know the the murder machine where
batman merges with like cyborgs and in
august becomes cyborg and that kind of
stuff just those twisted and really
really really screwed up situations and
so when when the world forger appears to
them he actually really kind of
challenges them without with a pretty
significant thing and it actually really
switches Batman over to kind of to his
side what he does he sits down and he
says in this multiverse that we live in
and because of what you guys have done
you've broken the source wall and
because you've broken the source wall
and because the Legion of Doom is trying
to bring back Perpetua is only a matter
of time before she arrives and so what
the world forger has been doing is
basically grabbing all these different
members of the Justice League from
across the entire multiverse and all
these different villains you see we're
powered beings and has kind of offered
them an option either join me and become
a part of my cause or stand against me
and be in prison for all eternity
presumably like forever and of course
the question is asked do you ally with
me or do you stand against me and the
you know by again in the same way the
Superman did by their thoughts and
feelings stand against him and so
they're immediately teleported to a
world I guess a version of apocalypse
that was created by the world forger now
a lot of this stuff is being thrown into
disarray a lot of the stuff is kind of
being thrown into flux and the reason
why is because when it comes to these
concepts for the most part they've kind
of been etched in stone when you talk
about like apocalypse and like Darkseid
the new gods all that kind of stuff by
and large it's it's the way it exists
right now is there's only one Darkseid
and throughout the entirety of like the
DC multiverse and there's only one
highfather throughout the entirety of DC
Multiverse there's only one apocalypse
and there's only one New Genesis that's
the way it works now when you were when
we were talking about like post-crisis
you know after 1985 when there was only
one universe and no multiverse then the
New Gods are basically out there in the
universe and is kind of walled off from
everything but now like like there's
only one of them in the entire
multiverse and so the implication seems
to be here the indication seems to be
that either this is a different universe
in and of itself entirely or it's a
whole other space that was created by
the world forger and that really seems
to be the case that it's not really a
different multiverse it's just in the
space at the various multiverses inhabit
out in the distance somewhere is kind of
like this little small localized galaxy
right like own closet your house and so
what this means is it like within this
small little space what the world forger
did is he built a version of apocalypse
100 times the size of the one that we
would normally see in the multiverse and
all those who stood against him are
imprisoned there and it's kind of crazy
because it's creating like it was
essentially a pocket reality out there
in the space that like inhabits the
multiverse it's pretty far out there and
it is really kind of mind-bending
and a little wild but it's still cool to
see because of course wal Superman's
trying to find his way out while he's
trying to like fight his way out of like
this darker space of course you have
like the rest of the Justice League who
are imprisoned by what's essentially an
alternate reality version of Lois Lane
who ended up siding with the world
forger and saying like I agree with his
cause and I do this because I'm tired of
seeing Jonathan Kent die in so many
different universes I'm doing this
because at the end of the day the lives
that we saved will outweigh the lives we
lose now the reality of this is actually
100% true and that's why I say like the
Justice League is actually kind of
stupid because what the world forger is
proposing to them is saying look if
Perpetua comes back she's gonna wipe
away everything in existence like
everything that exists right now she's
gonna wipe it all away and she's gonna
recreate it in the way that she believes
it should be done and so if that's the
case a countless number of beings from
across all things in existence are
going to die so what I ask of you is to
ally with me and then travel the
multiverse and and even move like beyond
the multiverse and find other versions
of yourself who will ally themselves
with me if they stand against me will
throw them in prison and of course the
Justice League said no but that's stupid
because what you're talking about is the
preservation of untold numbers you know
and the Justice League's like no because
we're talking about imprisoning people
and it's that's not cool you can't
imprison people for things they haven't
done but it's not as simple as like the
right thing versus the wrong thing is
it's as significant as like the
destruction of all things right like of
what use are moral principles if like
all of reality gets wiped away it's nice
to take this sort of high horse you know
stance and well we always gotta make
sure we do the right thing but like
sometimes you got to be the bad guy
because in order to like preserve all
existence you got to do bad things it's
the way it works there are no absolutes
and right and wrong there's all kinds of
gray areas and it's the only the old
Batman is the only one who realizes that
and the only one who seems to figure
that out because he's the only one that
stays behind and sides with the world
for sure and saying like yeah man
sometimes you just got to do bad things
like like that's just the way that it
works you know this kind of high horse
absolute I always do good I never do bad
kind of moral philosophy that the
Justice League walks around with that
can't work because at the end of the day
they can't do what needs to be done in
order to make sure that like everybody
gets safe it's kind of a cool thing and
it's kind of a cool moment because what
it really does is it takes the Justice
League as heroes and it looks them in
the face and says you guys are a
half-measure
you guys are all talk and like half
brawn at the end of the day you guys put
like goodness above what needs to be
done and it's kind of a cool thing right
because sometimes you got to sacrifice
your moral compass in order to get the
job done and so it's a it's a cool
little moment here because where the
Justice League is initially freed by
like the the son the future son of
Hawkgirl and Martian Manhunter and then
of course they're basically rescued by
like the Legion of Doom
right like thousand Estero and cheetah
and gorilla grodd but then we also end
up finding out that like they're also
joined by Darkseid presumably Darkseid
in the future and again that's where
things kind of get murky because if what
we're doing is we're talking about a
future story then it makes a lot more
sense if you say the events of this are
confined strictly to the multiverse but
for the most part Darkseid never really
seemed to indicate himself as a
character who would take up arms with
the Legion of Doom or like any
earthbound superhero group or even
supervillain group for the purpose of
like achieving a goal right like
Darkseid's always been a villain who
stands alone if he can't do it on its
own that means they're like it cannot be
done you know and so it's it's kind of a
cool thing because what this does is
this really kind of
Scott Snyder pointing to the future
importing to the idea of Perpetual and
saying this is really how bad it gets
like it gets bad enough that like
Darkseid ends up having to ally himself
with various superheroes or or like the
Legion of Doom because it's the only way
to preserve all things in existence and
Darkseid is nothing if not a being that
values his own his own preservation as
it was kind of a cool moment because
what is up happening here is that
Batman's kind of given a test by the
world for to write like a test of
loyalty and it's like if you truly want
to ally yourself with me then the one
thing you have to realize if Superman
he'll never back down you'll never take
the stance that you did Superman will
never take the stance of if you want to
make an omelet you got to break a few
eggs he's never gonna take that stance
instead like he's always gonna say no
there's got to be a way to Britain to
make that omelet without breaking some
eggs I don't know how it is maybe heat
vision he can just do that but still
like he'll he'll never take that
position and so because of that he'll
never ever be able to join our ranks
that place that he's in that pocket
reality does the world forger created
that Superman is confined in the bodies
that are there they'll always be filled
with Superman because in every single
universe that he's been to and in every
single multiverse that he's visited
Superman always stands against him and
that's when Batman that's when the
questions kind of asked by Batman if I
pull this son away if I yank it away
will he die fast and the wolf forger
says yes and then Batman says I'm sorry
Clark
but is what we have to do and basically
pulls the son away from Superman and
effectively kills him and it's kind of a
cool little moment because when that
happens Superman just sort of falls back
down to this reality that he's been in
and by all standards of measurement it
appears he's going to die now there are
a couple things that go on with regards
to the Justice a talking to the Legion
of Doom but it's an interesting moment
because it's kind of a coming together
right like the Legion of Doom says hey
look at the end of the day like we
realize that like the world for sure is
essentially wrong we kind of brought
this future about like we brought this
this this universe for this perspective
future about ourselves you know because
we were the ones who released her like
we were the ones who release perpetual
we're the ones that basically caused all
this if it hadn't been for us then like
none of this would have happened and so
what this means is that the Legion of
Doom is trying to make up for their past
sins I mean Lex Luthor's out of the
picture we never really find out what
he's become we just know that whatever
it is that he's become was like dark and
twisted and really screwed up and so it
was like okay you know so like they've
been trying to make amends this entire
time for what they'd previously done in
the past and so of course being chased
by by the forces of Lois Lane and being
chased you know kind of around this this
you know six dimension ultimately like
they managed to find a wormhole and
they're jettisoned out whether there's
Chaza this wormhole and and what that
does is basically bring him back
into like the main DC Universe and it's
it's a great little send-off it is
actually a great little moment and the
reason for this is because Lois Lane
basically tells him he looked Superman
was kind of put in stasis when he was
shot into this pond and then given like
images designed to sort of acclimate him
to like what earth was supposed to be
like so that when he didn't show up here
he wasn't like immediately threatened by
the first human he saw having no idea
what they were and then just attachment
right like that's not what would happen
instead he would show up and he would be
acclimated and relatively familiar with
the environment of Earth so that when he
saw humans he would realize okay they're
not the worst thing ever I mean like
even as a baby he wouldn't like
panicking and lose his mind or anything
like that and so what Lois says is like
we perfected that technology and what we
can do now is we can basically bombard
people with these rays of sorts we can
put you into a state where you fall
asleep and then condition you to
basically agree with us and so it's kind
of cool because when that happens they
literally start bombarding the ship
without the Legion of Doom and the
Justice League with all these rays
threatening to put them to sleep and
that's why the Justice League is shot
out and sent to this portal by the by
the the Legion of Doom because it's the
only way to get them back it's the only
way to get them out of this place and so
the Legion of Doom actually crashes
their ship and it's one of the it's one
of the most awesome things ever because
thousand Estero is like flying this ship
into the forces of Lois Lane and he's
like ah yes you know that old feeling
isn't it how can I ever forget the power
of fear and it's just it's just like
this amazing moment I feel like it could
have been like a little more grandiose
right like a little more a little more
drawn-out you know like the last ride of
thousand Estero and the Legion of Doom
it would have been pretty awesome and it
could have it could have been put
together pretty well but that's when we
end up basically you know emerging with
the scenario where Batman dons this god
armor and literally like just kind of
wages this conflict against the Justice
League that's one of the important
things to bear in mind here is that in
this particular moment Batman has
essentially become God right he has all
the power not really all the powers but
like the entire backing of of the world
forager behind him this vastly powerful
entity now again the way the world
forger functions is he says okay look I
basically create worlds and send them
out there like that's my purpose that's
my job that's the role that I play in
this entire multiverse and you know
potentially multiple multiverses
and so would that being the case he
literally turns his weapons on the
Justice League Batman goes to fight them
all like we just call him bad god like
that God goes to fight them all and all
the while he's basically calling out to
Superman and that's what we end up
finding out again Batman was kind of
planning this under the table the entire
time
under normal circumstances I would make
fun of this and just be like of course
Batman did because prep time or
something like that but I'm not because
it's actually pretty awesome
Batman trick to god it's actually pretty
cool I guess it's pretty amazing the way
this happens like it's all happening
under the current because what he knew
the one thing Batman knew and the one
thing the world forger did not know is
that Superman did this version of him
this this prime version of Superman is
more powerful than all the others right
it's what the world forger told Batman
he said look Batman asked the question
can he break out and the world forger
says well none of the other Superman
have been able to but this one's
different this is the prime Superman
what it seems to indicate is that like
this was the first universe and all the
other universes that are out there that
are part of the multiverse are templates
meaning it's the half-life effect right
you can only ever be half as much as the
thing that made you and so that's
basically what what seems to be going on
here is like none of the other Superman
out there are on par with the prime
Superman from the main DC Universe and
so where none of them were able to break
out it doesn't mean he cannot and that's
what Batman was banking on Batman was
baking on on this this gambit this idea
that if he were to pull the son away
that Superman wouldn't give up that he
would keep on trying to find a way and
that's exactly what happens the energy
put off by the Justice League kind of
combined with this sort of dream
sequence of Superman has basically leads
him to realize it like the Forenza D has
will always be there like that like what
he needed was this this kind of courage
to not give up in this moment when he
wanted to quit in this moment when he
wanted to stop he didn't and that all
these little stars all these things that
had basically kind of been thrown out
there by by Batman were available for
Superman to take advantage of and he
literally flies into a star and then
comes out but it seems like he's almost
infinitely more powerful than he was
before right because all it says is like
he's a million lanterns he's a million
flames lit by effort you know by by
steady hands was a he moves faster than
he ever has at a speed beyond physics
he's more powerful than he's ever been
Superman was already on par with with
most gods I would say he's probably
beyond them now right like it's God
Superman and God Batman in terms of the
power he possesses now how that compares
to Superman 1 million I don't know just
take a guess in whatever your guess is
is right I have no clue but in the
moment right now I would say the
Superman and Batman possess the power of
God and it's kind of a crazy thing to
see because one is up happening in the
way this kind of kind of gets laid out
is this almost kind of like a red
connoisseurs right I mean what Scott
Snyder says is that the way this world
forger works is like this when we think
about a singular universe like you have
all these events that transpire the
take place and then like crisis on
Infinite Earths happens and the way we
always imagined it is an event like
crisis on Infinite Earths wipes away
everything that was there before and
then you kind of go forward with like a
whole new creation that's not what Scott
Snyder's telling us what Scott Steiner
is telling us here is that reality gets
wiped away except for like the
characters and and you know to a degree
the fact there's somewhat like shells
right like they're vessels for their new
essences as they've been made by the
world forager to house right so like the
world forager designs a new version of
Superman he designs a new version of
Batman of Wonder Woman of all these
characters he wipes away the essence of
who they are and replaces it with that
new essence and so the only thing that
really changes is the environment around
them the world that they live in and to
a degree who they are as people in terms
of how they view the world and how it
impacts them but again like with the
with a possibility existing that like
this entire universe is gonna be wiped
away and it's all gonna be totally
obliterated Superman seemingly comes
flying out of nowhere now how Superman
got here we don't really know but given
the kind of power he possesses now I
would surmise Superman flew through two
dimensions to get here he broke out of
the sixth dimension flew through the
fifth dimension through the fourth
dimension and then came into the third
dimension so I would say he flew through
three dimensions in order to get here
Superman busted through dimensional
barriers in order to get here to where
the rest of the Justice League is and
with a singular punch lays out the world
fortune he doesn't kill him he just
totally like flattens him and lays him
out and the world for justice kind of
like wow now where he expects Superman
to kill him Superman says no we're not
going to kill you but with everything
that's coming with everything that's
happening everything with Perpetua we're
going to need you like we're gonna need
a power like yours to basically save us
to keep us protected or at the very
least to aid us in this massive battle
that we're gonna be facing without you
we stand no real chance here and so
that's when the Justice League is also
faced with the fact that what the Legion
of Doom had done is a it basically shown
up to the rest of the world and said hey
the Justice League broke the source wall
the Justice League set the multiverse on
its path to destruction the only way for
you guys to save us or the free to save
yourselves is to put your faith in us
now kind of a background story that was
going on here was that mr. Mixel Pitta
like you just kind of gone crazy and
basically sort of like wiping away
everything we're trying to destroy
everything and the Justice League
essentially called in bat-mite now
that's an actual Legion of Doom story
I'm pretty sure and so we're gonna cover
that as a separate video that way we can
kind of focus on it in its totality but
basically the takeaway from this is that
the Legion of Doom they're now on their
way to basically bringing in Perpetua
Lex Luthor when two Lex Corp essentially
sacrifice them
self you have amanda waller who was
subjugated by what was left of the
legion of tim they took all this
information on we're like the most
powerful and dangerous villains
throughout the entire world were being
held
it's basically year of the villain
number one all the things that kind of
go into it they either set the stage or
came out of it and so not only that once
it's all said and done and Lex Luthor
begins to re-emerge what seems to go on
here and I could be wrong but what seems
to go on here is that Lex Luthor
basically reverts back to like his dark
side war version Lex Luthor begins to
turn into Darkseid again I don't know if
that's true I'm not a hundred percent
sure that's true it's kind of hard to
tell but that's what it looks like so
let me know what you guys think down in
the comments section but if you are new
here two comments explain make sure you
guys have the sub button to become part
of the rob4 if you guys enjoyed this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]
you
[Music]